hey Becca hey Kim alright so we're
talking about how people got to the
Americas today so when did people first
arrived in North America was Columbus
the first one so no he was not you know
back in the day people believed that
actually pre Columbus no one was here
but in this video I'm not going to be
talking about if right there definitely
were people here but I'll be talking
about how people got here when and who
they were and so these are the questions
that historians and archaeologists are
still debating today so Kim who are
archeologists archaeologists are
scholars who work in the land they will
dig in the places where people lived in
the past find remains of earlier
civilizations and use that evidence to
build a picture of what life was like in
a place before there was a written
record so a lot of the history we'll
talk about in this video has to do with
different evidence and competing
evidence that archeologists have found
in the land that we now call the United
States so as I mentioned we're not
arguing if there were people here
because there definitely were there were
even big cities and towns and people
living together in societies that look a
lot like what the colonists were trying
to make as well yeah I think people
often have the misconception that Native
Americans were primarily
hunter-gatherers who pretty much lived
in very small bands that didn't leave
much of a record of buildings or living
sites they were more nomadic but people
were all over North America and they had
societies that were very different from
each other some of which were very
complex politically and some of which
were quite large cities this city here
is Cahokia which is I know low I love
the name Cahokia close to modern-day st.
Louis this is the largest
city in the Americas about 40,000 to
maybe 60,000 people lived in this city
is gonna be the largest city in the
Americas until the 1780s when
Philadelphia has more people Wow that is
just really remarkable so 40,000 people
here in Cahokia and there were so
historical records that said that there
was no one here well you know history is
something that is highly influenced by
the kind of narratives that historians
want to tell we know that humans as a
species today originated somewhere in
Africa and and spread throughout Europe
and Asia to other land masses so how did
they get the North American continent so
we don't know for sure but
archaeologists and historians have
pretty much agreed that the Native
Americans came through the Bering Strait
which as you can see right here this was
this big Ice Sheet during the Ice Age
that connected Asia and North America
through Alaska so the Native Americans
came from Asia they were Asian really
and they walked across the Bering Strait
and down into North America what is now
water at that time was covered with ice
so I'm guessing they're following herds
of animals that they might like to eat
yes exactly and these were called the
Paleo Indians so they were the first
Indians Paleo Indians really means
ancient people so these were the ancient
people and they were again following
different animals so historians estimate
that the Paleo Indians came down through
the Bering Strait about 13,000 years ago
so now that's a long time ago but now
different archaeological evidence may
point to the Paleo Indians coming over
much earlier than that actually more
like 16,000 years ago now yeah I mean
3,000 years is a significant difference
I mean think about 3,000
years earlier than today we'd be talking
a thousand BCE so today archaeologists
and historians kind of argue about when
exactly it was and lots of different
evidence and fossils and archaeological
digs are coming up with evidence that
points us more towards 16,000 and 13,000
so it was actually in 1925 when
archaeologists found the first Clovis
point so they're called Clovis points
because in 1925 archaeologists found
these kind of arrowheads they're very
small probably nothing more than like 2
centimeters but they found them in
Clovis New Mexico so over here in New
Mexico and estimated that they were
about 13,000 years old so that's kind of
our old hypotheses that humans were
hunting with these Clovis points 13,000
years ago probably buffalo or bison or
any other kind of larger animal that
they would need to carve out of stone
these arrowheads to shoot without bow
and arrow most likely these larger
animals to eat so this is some of the
first evidence that leads archaeologists
to an interpretation of when human
habitation first occurred in North
America exactly and this was kind of the
overwhelming consensus for a really long
time
all throughout the 1900s people are
digging up different artifacts all
across North America finding more Clovis
points and kind of all agree was about
13,000 years ago that they came again
down through here and all around and
that's why we're founding these Clovis
points but then in 1997 not too long ago
at all actually so a Vanderbilt
archaeologist his name is Tom DeLay
found evidence of humanity in shyla all
the way down here so it seemed that the
humans were living about 14,000 years
ago so it would have only taken them a
thousand years to get all the way from
up here down here so now there's kind of
two competing hypotheses you
they traveled by land through the Bering
Strait and got all the way down here in
just a thousand years by foot I mean
they're really moving or they actually
were using some sort of maritime vessel
to get down there in a boat but there's
just these small different theories
within this archaeological movement
about exactly how they moved about and
exactly when there's also this new
branch of DNA science which is
enlightening historians about who the
first Native Americans were and who
their direct ancestors are these
paleo-indians
they're coming from Alaska they're
coming from Siberia I guess up there so
are their direct ancestors Russians
Asians the DNA evidence points that the
Paleo Indians were most closely related
to the Asians they moved through Asia
and down through the Bering Strait
interesting so that kind of corroborates
the archaeological record right if we
say that somewhere between 10 and 16
thousand years ago there was a
splintering of this population from the
Asian population I the Bering Strait
became water again and now in sort of
classic Darwin fashion we have two
separated populations evolving
differently exactly and the DNA
definitely corroborates that evidence so
today archaeologists and DNA scientists
are working together to figure out
really which of these hypotheses is more
true did they move by land or was it by
water and they want to learn more about
exactly who were they yeah they were
Asian but how did they distance
themselves from the rest of the East
Asian population and really what
motivated them to come down through the
Bering Strait and explore this territory
one thing that I think is really
important to take away from this is that
if you look at the history of the
Americas you start 16,000 years ago and
the history of Europeans in America is
just a tiny fraction of that time so the
history of
starts long before 1776 long before 1492
it starts when the first people came to
America 15,000 years ago and the Paleo
Indians started their own American
history much before Columbus sailed the
ocean blue in 1492 right and
archeologists are continuing to learn
more about the first Americans and
really the beginning of American history